Yvonne now as the strength and grace of
a ballet dancer and the agility of an
athlete watching our pole dancing
there's no doubt that this is an
extremely demanding sport the 48-year
old is mastered the swings and poses
almost perfectly Yvonne is the world
champion in her field poland's is smiley
pole dancing is my life you approach the
pool turn pirouettes and you climb Dan
Octus is allowed from tricks hops
cuisine and you learn new tricks from
seeing them on video or another dancer
doing them cookies we get us and then I
tried the Mack myself if on Hulk is
mostly self-taught the former gymnast
began pole dancing about six years ago
since then her whole life has revolved
around it
Zander taisha landmark oh Sh listing
published pole art magazine Germany's
only magazine devoted to pole dancing
their aim is to promote the sport
nowadays enthusiasts can bowl dance in
more than 120 studios across Germany
delicious the first Association most
people have with pole dancing a strip
club strip club stripping album people
gradually they're realizing that it's
not just about writhing around on a pole
it's a real sport it's strenuous it's
visually appealing and the image of pole
dancing is changing diamond patient in
addition a foolish of the spirit of gold
and silver that prejudice is deep-seated
largely because pole dancing first came
to prominence in the strip club scene as
a sport it's relatively new the society
pole dancing emerged in the United
States got some years ago the early
keep-fit movements tried to turn into a
sport the trend came to Germany maybe
ten years ago for my own flesh faltoyano
Deutschland become diesel trend since
then it's become well established in
Germany here eight women are attendings
under license course it focuses on the
fun side of physical exercise skin
clings to the pole better than fabrics
dude so these pole dancers are lightly
closed everyone here is used to the same
skeptical questions
that's most pointed they assume that
means i do striptease that's nonsense
you were the same from people just say
oh my god thailand's then come to us
more oh my god that's good all puns
anger I'm an opera singer and when I'm
among my colleagues and I say I do pull
down saying everyone initially looks
shocked as soon as a Shahid Kapoor be
born Hulk as a Danish dancer as a guest
she wants to profit from the world
champions experience and give her own
moves a final polish
okay sick Yvonne is one of the best in
the world so of course I want to be
trained by her um I'm right now training
to compete in the danish national champ
and I want everything to be perfect pole
dancing is carved out a space for itself
in pop culture
the Thomas this is my dream is that
someday pole dancing will be an Olympic
disciplined force and that there will be
more studios more enthusiasm more
dancers because something this beautiful
simply has to be passed on on vayas uvas
to dismiss my life a fight again in
Germany at least the future looks bright
sand or I shall also offers courses for
children without any erotic poses of
course she hopes one day pole dancing
will be a widely practice sport